from the University of Maryland College
Park take it away
thank you so much for having me here
today
so in this talk
with fair explainable and lawful using
approaches from information Theory
okay so the motivation for This research
comes from the growing use of machine
learning in these really high stakes
applications
like hiring education lending Health
Care Etc
for instance more than 50 percent of
companies are using algorithms at some
stages in their hiring pipeline
similar algorithms are widely used in
lending and for credit decision making
Etc
so while these algorithms are really
good at learning all patterns present in
the data
but blindly learning all patterns can
sometimes have unintended consequences
like propagating biases and disparities
with respect to gender race age
nationality Etc
or sometimes taking decisions that we do
not quite know or understand why that
decision was taken or what we could do
to avert the outcome
so my research interests lie at the
intersection of fairness explainability
and policy
and towards answering these urgent
questions uh What uh I propose is
techniques that use information Theory
uh statistics and causality
so an explainability the questions that
I'm interested in are how do we provide
not just any explanation but
explanations that can reliably guide
towards changing the outcome of a model
and then In algorithmic fairness the
kind of questions that I've been looking
into is how do we quantify not just
disparity
but the sources of disparity like which
feature or attribute is actually
responsible for causing the disparities
in the model
and to answer these questions in today's
talk I will talk about some of my recent
Works in this area
spending more time on our recent work on
robust counter factual explanations
so what are counter factual explanations
let's say you apply for a loan and the
loan gets rejected and we would want to
tell the customer or applicant what they
need to do to be accepted for the loan
so counterfactual explanations become
the closest point on the other side of
the decision boundary that is getting
accepted by a model like increase your
income by 10K and then you will be
accepted for this loan
but then what happens is that all of
these machine learning models being used
to make these decisions are updated
quite frequently sometimes they might be
updated due to retraining on a few
additional data points or they might be
retrained using some uh on an additional
seed or changing the hyper parameter and
then the models can change and when
these models change sometimes these
counterfactual explanations can become
invalid like you tell the applicant to
increase their income by 10K and they
actually do it and come back but now
because your model has updated the
counterfactual explanation is still not
valid and they are still getting
rejected for the loan
so the question that they ask over here
is how do we provide counter factual
explanations that are not only close but
also robust to these kinds of model
changes
[Music]
so this is the problem statement that
we're given a data point x that is
getting rejected by the model so MX is
the model outcome which gives a value
between 0 and 1 so less than 0.5 means
you're getting rejected then the goal is
to find another point or a counter
factual X Prime which will be accepted
by this model
and also it will satisfy some of these
other requirements like it is as close
to the Old Point as possible it's also
going to remain valid after changes to
the model
and then the third requirement is it
should also be a more realistic point
with respect to the data manifold like
you can't change people ask people to
change something that they cannot change
like change your city of birth or
something like that
to answer to
counter factual stability
which quantifies yes so one and three
are not the same
uh no one is just close just you cross
the boundary but three is realistic
means it should be also related to the
data points or line a more dense region
of the data point data manifold
that's a good question
so we're going to propose a measure of
counterfactual stability which
quantifies the robustness of these uh
counter factuals under natural model
changes
with probabilistic guarantees
so I started looking at this problem
while I was at JP Morgan where they were
more interested in tree based models
which are non-differentiable
but now we are also looking into neural
networks which are inherently
differentiable and for differentiable
models we find that the models local
Lipschitz Behavior actually plays an
important role in uh determining whether
the point is going to be robust or not
so this is Joint work with my PhD
student Faisal uh Irfan who is another
PhD student at UMD and sumitra and
Danielle are with the explainability
team at JP Morgan
okay so what is this measure of
counterfactual stability
so before defining counterfectual
stability we are trying to axiomatically
think through what would be the
desirable properties for such a measure
of counterfactual stability
so one desired desirable property would
be of course if the model output is a
value between 0 and 1 if the output
value is
6 or 0.7 we might think that okay this
this value is or this point is more
likely to remain stable and valid after
model changes
but then we find that just high output
value may not be enough so the second
property is that if several points
around the point that we are interested
in have a high model output value then
that would make the point more stable
and less likely to be invalidated
but then uh the third thing that we look
at is just High local mean is also not
enough so you might also want low
variability in the region where the
point is located
so we are seeking High local mean value
and low local variability
so these two these three properties lead
us to propose this uh measure of counter
factual stability which looks something
like this
so for a counter factual point we would
generate a bunch of gaussian points
around it and then we would compute its
mean value so high local mean
and low local variability where this is
the Lipschitz constant of the model
okay so now we have a measure of counter
factual stability how do we say whether
this is a good measure or what kind of
guarantees can we give for this measure
so to give guarantees on the robustness
or validity first we have to think
through what kind of model changes are
we really interested in because models
can change drastically and there can be
a lot of different kinds of changes that
could happen to a model
so to understand this we propose this
abstraction of naturally occurring model
change
so what is naturally occurring model
change so to give some background these
are some related works on robustness of
counter factuals
so an existing Works uh an assumption
that is made is that the old model and
the new model are bounded in the
parameter space like if it's a new
neural network the two neural networks
parameters are bounded by some Delta
and then they also go on to apply a
Minimax optimization problems to solve
or to find robust counter factuals
but our assumptions come from this
observation that these models can
actually change quite a lot in the
parameter space but uh they their output
values on the data set doesn't change a
whole lot
this idea also relates to a body of work
called rashemon effect which deals with
the properties of models making similar
decisions on a data set
So based on these observations this is a
proposed abstraction of this naturally
occurring model change
so visually this is how it looks what we
are saying is that the new model is
going to be centered around the old
models output value
then the second assumption we make is
that if the old model is lip shits then
the new model is also going to be lip
ships
and then the third assumption that we
make is this variance assumption that on
the points that lie actually on the data
manifold the variability of the new
model is going to be less so the points
that actually lie on the dense regions
of the data manifold
are somewhat acting like anchors while
in the other regions or sparse regions
of the data manifold the change model
can actually vary a lot
and then under these assumptions of
naturally occurring model change we are
able to give probabilistic guarantees on
our measure of robustness
the guarantee looks something like this
that under naturally occurring model
change the new model's output is going
to be greater than our proposed
robustness measure with a high
probability
and then if the new model's output is
going to be higher than our proposed
robustness measure then we can use the
proposed robustness measure as a
reliable lower bound
for the output of the new model so if
the robustness value is high then we
would expect the change models outputs
to also be high and hence the point will
be more likely to be accepted or lie on
the accepted side of the data manifold
the proof of this uses concentration
bounds for lip sheets functions of
gaussian random variables
okay so now they have a measure and then
how to integrate this measure into an
algorithm
so in our algorithm we introduce this
concept called conservative counter
factuals so to give a sense here this is
the rejected applicant
so the closest counter factual will be a
which is just the closest point on the
other side
the closest data support a realistic
counter factual will be B which is on
the other side and also on the data
manifold
and then the conservative counters
actually something like this which is uh
also which is on the data manifold which
is on the accepted side and also
somewhat well within the decision
boundary
and then we are also able to incorporate
relaxations of this measure into an
optimization formulation and propose an
algorithm called T-Rex which is a
theoretically robust explanations
and uh yes I think in the optimization
formulation what we do is we are able to
incorporate this robustness measure as a
constraint in the optimization and then
we can solve for it yes
can you for a moment take a minute to
explain what counter factual means in a
fairness relationship yeah that's true
so this is explaining explain literature
uh so here counter factual in this
context means let's say I apply for a
loan and I get rejected so what is the
hypothetical point which will be
accepted by the model so in causality
counter factual is used in the sense
that if I give this drug to a patient
and the patient dies if I had
hypothetically not given the drug what
would have happened
so here the word is used in that sense
that if I had increased my income by 10K
if I had 10K more then I would get
accepted by the model so it's like the
nearest Point not nearest a point on the
other side which is going to get
accepted by the model so in some sense I
want to poison the data to get error
results I I I'm trying to understand
because you're assuming the moral
changes no the so I'm not retraining the
model uh the model is going to be fixed
with respect to this model what do you
need to do to be accepted but then the
model can change without consideration
for that counter factual that was given
it can change due to various internal
reasons like you might retrain it on
some additional data points or change
the seed or hyper parameter so the
changed model is not related to the
explanation that was given
okay
thanks
okay so then with this algorithm we also
have several experimental results uh I'm
not including all the details here but
to summarize we propose a quantification
of counter factual stability with
probabilistic guarantees
we also have some possibility results
for targeted model changes like so what
I'm saying is that with high probability
among these naturally occurring model
changes you will be reliable but it
doesn't mean you cannot deliberately
construct some targeted model changes
for which you will fail
and then our algorithm is able to find
counter factors that are quite close
robust and realistic we have
experimental data results on many other
tabular data sets and this also
outperforms some of the min max
optimization type approaches that I had
talked about before
so some of the ongoing problems that
we're looking into are we are trying to
look into uh making counter factors
robust and realistic over time if
there's a Time evolving model
and also I'm interested in privacy and
fairness problems for counter factuals
okay so uh Switching gears a little bit
now I will be talking about my work on
fairness where the question that I'm
interested in is
how do we identify and explain the
sources of disparity like which feature
or attribute is more responsible for the
disparity in a model
so this is the setting that we are
thinking about so we have a bunch of
features going into a model and taking
decisions on acceptance or rejection
and then uh sometimes what happens is
that let's say this is an application
for this is an example of hiring a
software engineer for a very safety
critical application
some features might be deemed more
important than others like coding tests
might be deemed as more important for
hiring a software engineer
and this is also a question that the
courts care about today like uh
disparate impact or disparity may be
exempt if it can be justified by
something called an occupational
necessity
like coding test may be deemed as an
occupational necessity for a software
engineering job or weight lifting may be
an occupational necessity for
firefighters so that they can lift
victims out of a building
but then other features like aptitude
test may not be deemed as a critical
feature uh as in this Landmark court
case of cribs versus Duke Power
so the question that we are asking here
is given a
Shepherd or a lawyer how do we say if
the disparity that you're observing is
exempt or non-exempt
so our contribution is a systematic
measure of non-exempt disparity
which is the bias or disparity that is
not justified by the critical features
so again the problem statement or
notations are going to be as follows
uh we have this bunch of features X1 X2
X3 y hat is the model output Z denotes
The Protector attribute like gender
arrays Etc
the critical features are denoted by XC
and the non-critical or general features
are noted by x g
and then we also assume that all of
these data and this is an assumption In
fairness literature that all of these uh
features X1 X 2 X 3 are generated from
an underlying data generation process or
structural causal model
where you have some of these latent
random variables that you do not get to
see U1 U2 u3 uh and this sensitive
attribute is z which is gender race Etc
then the question is given a choice of
critical features what is a good measure
of this non-exempt disparity
so once you have a measure it could be
used in different ways either for
auditing or for training where you can
use this non-exam disparity as a
regularizer with a loss function
the question that we are interested in
is a more definitional question that
what is a good measure of this
non-exempt disparity
so I'll talk briefly about some of the
popular definitions of fairness which is
statistical parity and equalized odds
so statistical parity is something that
you might be familiar with which is says
that the output is fair if it's entirely
independent of the sensitive attribute Z
and you can write statistical parity as
Mutual information statistical disparity
as Mutual information
when the criticism for statistical
parity is that it sometimes disregards
the critical necessities
like if the coding test happens to be
correlated with Z this is a model that
you would get without using any kind of
fairness regularizer but when you use a
fairness regularizer which minimizes
statistical parity to minimize the
correlation with z and the output you
might end up not placing any importance
on the coding test score and you might
be taking decisions entirely on a
non-critical feature
to address this problem with statistical
parity another definition is equalized
dots which says that the output is
independent that z and y hat should be
independent conditioned on the true
labels or the past labels
the perfect classifier satisfies
equalized dot so if a testifier is 100
accuracy it will satisfy equalized dots
but equalized dots is also face some
criticism that let's say we are
accepting everybody in the past everyone
who is being above a threshold have been
accepted and we are still continuing to
give a perfect classifier which accepts
all of them
but then here in this scenario uh the
coding test score might not be
correlated with Z but the aptitude test
score happens to be correlated with z
and then there's a lot of discussion on
even though we are getting a perfect
classifier it is the aptitude test score
which is propagating the correlation
and aptitude test score is not a
critical feature
so uh this leads to a lot of debate and
discussion and our approach actually
adopts the middle ground between
statistical parity and equalized dots
using domain knowledge
where we first assume that we have the
critical features given to us and then
our question becomes what is a good
measure of non-exempt disparity
some candidate measures that we look
into
kickoff is conditional Mutual
information or conditional Independence
that for the the model is fair if the
output y hat is independent of Z
conditioned on the critical feature like
coding test score
and the information theoretic
quantification of this measure is
conditional Mutual information which is
a mutual information between z and y hat
conditioned on XC
but then one observation that we make in
this work is that conditional dependence
can also sometimes falsely detect
dependencies even when a model is
causally fair
so to understand this I'm going to look
into a counter example now
so this is we are going to look into an
example of causally fair model so here Z
is the protected attribute and U is a
latent random variable that is
independent of Z which could denote
something like inner ability
then the coding test score happens to
depend on both Z and u and then the
other features are probably depending
only on you
and let's say the model is able to
distill out this U from all of these
features and take its decisions based
entirely on just you and not on Z
by causal definitions of fairness in
existing works this model will be deemed
Fair because it says that a counter
factual fairness or causal fairness this
counterfaction is different from the
other factual but counterfactual
fairness says that the output Z doesn't
vary with Z after fixing all the latent
random variables U
so here what's going on is that we have
Z is independent of Y hat so the output
is independent of Z but when a condition
on this critical feature XC it becomes
dependent this also relates to classical
informational Theory examples and mutual
information is greater than zero but the
conditional Mutual formation is greater
than zero but uh informational
information is not
so this issue leads to one desirable
property that we want our measure of
non-exempt disparity to be zero even
when a model is causally fair
so we see that conditional Mutual
information does not satisfy this causal
fairness property
and it is this limitation of conditional
Mutual information which leads us to
look into a body of work and information
Theory which is called partial
information decomposition
but partial information decomposition
does is it further decomposes
conditional Mutual information into two
quantities called unique information and
synergistic information
and then it is this unique information
measured actually satisfies our causal
fairness property as well as some others
so what is this unique information
we look at two very similar looking
examples here in the first case the
critical feature is Z Plus U but the
output is u
so the output has no information about
protected attribute Z in which case this
is causally fair
but in the second case the critical
feature is you but the output is Z Plus
U so the output has some information
about the Z that is not arising from the
critical feature X
and conditional dependence or
conditional Mutual information is
greater than zero for both these
examples
ideally we are looking for a measure
here that is able to distinguish between
these two scenarios
and unique information enables that so
what unique information does is uh
so it's a conditional Mutual information
between these random variables when
only the marginals between z y hat and Z
XC are preserved but the joint
distribution of the three random
variables are allowed to vary
and this also has a Venn diagram
interpretation where if you have mutual
information and conditional Mutual
information
unique information happens to be the
intersectional region between Mutual
information and conditional Mutual
information
that also satisfies our causal fairness
property as well as some other
properties
okay so uh to summarize we started out
with statistical disparity and mutual
information which is the entire
correlation between z y hat but then
this does not allow exemptions for
business saps or critical features
so we tried conditional dependence but
then for conditional dependence is the
region which lies outside of mutual
information that is it can sometimes be
non-zerable when Mutual information is
zero
so we propose unique information as a
candidate measure of non-exempt
disparity and this satisfies several
desirable properties two that I already
talked about as well as the natural
monotonicity properties as well which
actually conditional Mutual information
doesn't satisfy
so the monotonicity properties are
something like if all features are
critical then it will go to zero as you
add drop more and more features from the
critical set it will be monotonically
increasing and if no feature is critical
it will become the conditional the
mutual information
then there are some more nuanced issues
and I'll be a bit quick from here that
even unique information doesn't address
which is this example of masking
so this is like let's say an ad is shown
to women with men with high inner
ability in women with low inner ability
and it is not shown to these two other
fractions of people
so here the output is an xor of Z and u
which will be independent but then
there's some causal dependence
uh between Z and this output y hat which
is not desirable because the ad is not
being shown to women with high inner
ability who actually uh might qualify
for this job but they do not get to see
the ad
so here uh this kind of disparity is
called Mass disparity and for Mass
disparity we have some impossibility
results that are purely observational
measure might not be able to correctly
capture Mass disparity in a lot of
situations
and even in causality these have
connections with non-faithful causal
models
and then we also propose a causal
measure that satisfies not only five but
six desirable properties including this
this scenario of mass disparities
so our observational measure is a lower
bound to our proposed causal measure
that satisfies six desirable properties
but this causal measure requires
knowledge of the structural causal model
and the relationships which may or may
not always be available
so we also have some experimental
results uh so for when we want a
scenario where the causal relationships
are known we start with synthetic data
for synthetic data we are able to use
all of these measures as regularizers
with the loss function and see how
accuracy and fairness trade off with
each other so we have the total
disparity which is decomposed into
exempt and non-exempt disparity and this
is further decomposed into Mast and
visible and similarly masked visible
non-exempt
uh disparities
then when the cause of relationships are
not known we cannot compute the causal
measure that I proposed but what we can
do is we can still use all of these
regularizers that have been proposed uh
the observational regularizers and under
certain assumptions on faithfulness uh
these measures do capture a lot of the
scenarios that I talked about
then we also have some other work which
incorporates these measures on Twitter
data and tries to quantify exempt and
non-exempt topic biases
a related question that falls out is
what is the potential contribution of
each individual feature like you don't
just have critical or non-critical
features but now you have a large number
of features and you want to quantify
what is the contribution of each of
those features to the disparity
then while I was at CMU I also collected
a graduate admissions data set and
applied some of these partial
information decomposition measures on
that data set to see how which feature
is having unique contribution and which
feature is having synergistic
contribution on the feature on the
features uh on the disparity of the
decisions
foreign research
we are also interested in the problem of
accuracy and fairness trade-offs where
in my prior work I used techniques from
turn off information to quantify the
trade-offs between accuracy and fairness
and this turn of information technique
can also be used to understand if some
features are missing or if some features
are not providing enough information to
separate the two features how can you
choose features or when choosing new
features help and when choosing new
features doesn't help
so now we are also looking into
extending this partial information
decomposition kind of ideas in local and
Global fairness settings in Federated
learning this is a work in preparation
but in Federated learning the situation
becomes that there's a local fairness
and a global fairness because every uh
every uh every com node is acting on its
own local data set but at the central
level there's also global data set with
which you have to ensure fairness
and then these are some works that
started while I was at JP Morgan uh so
in the finance setting there's another
the restrictions of the regulations and
for fairness are little bit different
so what they want is that the model
developers who are developing or
training the model should not have
direct access to the sensitive
attributes so the sensitive attribute
row or column is missing and then this
problem is addressed from various
perspectives sometimes people allow a
separation between model developers and
a compliance team where the compliance
team might have the entire data set but
the model developers don't
and some of these techniques have also
been introduced in a feature selection
for fairness problem which is also being
used in the fair lending pipeline at JP
Morgan
but there is a lot more to do here at
the intersection of fairness and
explainability so we'll conclude with my
research Vision which is to build the
foundations of reliable machine learning
using techniques from information and
coding Theory causality and probability
and statistics and then connecting it to
applications that directly influence
people's lives like hiring education
Finance as well as some other
applications that I'm quite interested
in
thank you so much
[Applause]
any questions
thank you for the nice talk um on your
first in the first part have you thought
about connecting with a recourse
literature
um because it seems like these methods
are very effective to give folks uh
recourse yeah
the course so I think it's called
algorithmic records in some literature
it's called counterfeiture fairness and
some but yeah the goal is to tell people
that this is what you need to do to get
to the other side but this is what you
need to do to also get to the other side
in a more reliable manner like like say
if someone is giving an exam enter the
pass marks is 40 I don't want to tell
them just get 41. I want to tell them
get maybe 50 or be a little bit well
within the boundary so that you can
reliably pass the test or qualify for
the toll and the second question is and
there's a lot of literature on
certifying robustness of models I
understand that here it's um yeah yeah
that's a very good question so in
certifying robustness literature yeah
it's like they generate points around
them model around the data point and try
to give robustness guarantees but I
think the difference with this approach
and robustness literature is that there
the perturbations here the perturbations
in the min max approaches the
perturbations are applied on the model
uh like for the neural network you would
want to perturb it with the worst Delta
but here the perturbations are uh sorry
I think in this box so in in robustness
literature the perturbations replied in
the data point like around X how much
would you perturb it with and then you
train the model but here the
perturbations are applied on the model
like for a model what is the worst case
perturbation for that model and then
they apply min max approaches and what
we are doing is we are not even applying
the max approaches we are looking at
this kind of a probabilistic perspective
where you can just optimization
optimization and get uh I guess
guarantees for a large number of models
not like worst case Delta models is this
a uniform Bound for the samples or
is
a guarantee on Sample because of the
model prediction right yeah yeah so is
that averaged over all the samples yeah
both the m is also a random variable and
X is also random variable so the model
is also random and the sample the
samples are also random
foreign
furnace is equivalent to demographic
parity foreign
I'm wondering if if there is
equal opportunity is equalized out of an
equal opportunity are connected they're
like z and y hat should be independent
of each other conditioned or through
level one or condition of the historical
wife
so equivalence of odds it would also
translate to having equal accuracy on uh
all groups when you actually train the
model but the criticism with equalized
dots is that equalized dots as he uses
the past labels that you already have
like in the past who has been successful
you have the data for that so it
conditions on those two levels that it
already has that in the past who has
been successful but in the past version
successful it can also encode a lot of
label buyers which is not specifically
looked at and ideally we would want to
have an equalized thoughts where we have
the future labels for who will be
successful in future but that is
something we don't have so when we use
the past labels to do that then past
label bias propagates and then there are
all of these issues that which feature
was responsible for the disparity and
which feature was not because I think a
more explainability plus fairness kind
of approach uh is is going to be useful
um so this uh unique Mutual information
thing uh
to empirically estimate this thing yeah
something I didn't expect
once you have the marginal distributions
not the marginal electric just the joint
distributions
then it becomes a convex optimization
problem but the challenge is how do you
reliably get these joint uh
distributions and again for different
random variables there are some nice
things you can do for gaussian random
variables there are some nice results
uh so and here so far we have used
simpler techniques because z and y has a
binary and x c was also somewhat uh like
easy feature but uh it is a problem that
I'm looking into and I think there's
possibility of using other techniques
here maybe uh there's this work on
Mutual information neural estimation
mind and some things along those lines I
think I also there could be other
techniques also what Lalita was talking
about in her talk and I think also from
optimal transport there was nice talk in
the morning so I think there is
possibility of uh using other techniques
to get improved estimators
thank you so much
next